it's very important given the
nature of the climate crisis right now
for the general public to have an
understanding of what progress is or is
not actually happening
and i think many readers right now
they'll see these hundreds and hundreds
of companies making these
big bold climate uh claims
and they would be forgiven to think that
you know we're well on our way to
meeting the emission reduction
trajectory we need to be on
and the reality of the matter is we're
just not on that trajectory
and it and a key reason for this sort of
disconnect
is the use of offsets that aren't doing
what they claim to be doing
we have a massive potential for sort of
willful blindness
we can convince ourselves of things
regardless of what the facts are
and so that's what tends to happen in
these cases it's not that it's not that
anybody is setting out to commit
climate fraud they they sort of walk
themselves into a situation
and they convince themselves of one
thing and that allows them to convince
themselves of another thing
but at the end of the day they're doing
something that makes no sense at all
my name is ben elgin i wrote the story
about how the billion dollar market for
carbon offsets is setting back the fight
against climate change
so one of the challenges in reporting on
carbon offsets and trying to figure out
what's going on
is really finding good experts who
have been steeped in this marketplace
and are willing to candidly talk about
it
one of the best people for this is a
fellow named mark trexler and i've been
talking to him for more than
a decade my name is mark trexler i've
worked in climate change for the last
30 years i was actually hired by the
world resources institute in washington
to work on the first
carbon offset project in 1988
in terms of defining a carbon offset the
one of the beauties
so to speak of greenhouse gases sort of
the silver lining of greenhouse gases
you can when you put up a molecule of
co2 into the atmosphere
it can be anywhere in the planet in
seven days
and therefore you know if there's an
option to reduce
emissions on the other side of the
planet and you can do that very cheaply
as compared to doing it in your factory
for example
then why not pay that person that
factory on the other side of the planet
to reduce their emissions
then you are in a sense offsetting
your emissions and the atmosphere
doesn't really see your
emissions anymore so carbon offsets have
been
been around for quite some time and they
were actually key with these
international
track climate agreements such as the
kyoto protocol which
mandated the wealthiest countries
reduced their greenhouse gas emissions
the treaty was signed on the 11th of
december 1997.
decided the business community
in general saw carbon offsets as a huge
opportunity
to comply with whatever policies and
measures might be coming down the pike
on climate change much more cost
effectively
we've seen a huge surge in companies
making big proclamations about how
they're going carbon neutral or zeroing
out
all of their carbon emissions we're
going to reduce our carbon footprint to
net zero
unilever is committing to net zero
emissions
we can achieve a net zero emissions
world
we began looking at these corporate
claims of
dramatically reduced emissions and we
noticed so many of these companies
were using carbon offsets to uh to to
achieve these aims
and as we begin to look at the carbon
offset projects themselves
what we found is that the environmental
benefits claimed by these companies are
not actually what they
what they seem to be
and as we sort of saw and spotted a
number of these very aggressive carbon
offset projects which appeared to be
generating
inflated credits or bogus credits we saw
a number of them were associated with
the nature conservancy
this surprised us the nature conservancy
is the world's biggest environmental
group
they have about a billion dollars a year
in revenues
and they've been around for seven
decades uh they've preserved about 125
million acres of land
uh and they've done so many good works
over the years and they've been
very strong in terms of working with
corporate partners the nature
conservancy has taken a different
approach a very pragmatic and
pro-business approach they will not go
out and criticize a big polluter
but they're very happy to work with them
some might say that well that's selling
out but others would say
and and those at the nature conservancy
would say
these companies have deep pockets they
can help fund
important preservation work and we have
absolutely no problem working with them
on this stuff
so uh companies are uh very warm
and and um they've partnered with the
nature conservancy for
for many years and uh yeah it definitely
lends a
sheen of credibility to these
20 new projects to visit disney world
this year
[Music]
if you look at for instance disney
that's a sprawling company with
theme parks and cruise lines that burn
up diesel fuel
they have office buildings and
television studios that consume
electricity
so these companies are trying to make
major major reductions in their carbon
footprints but it's
very difficult to change these
fundamental ways their businesses
operate
so disney has been a big buyer of carbon
offsets
that are orchestrated by the nature
conservancy
one of the projects that they buy from
is called pennsylvania ridges
and that's a plot of land most of the
land is actually about a three hour
drive outside of philadelphia
interestingly this land three thousand
of these acres
was actually acquired by the nature
conservancy
in the late 1990s this land was
imminently threatened there was a
pending logging contract on this land
so they they do what they they've done
so well for all of these years which is
they go out
they raise money from local
philanthropists and they go buy this
land to protect it from developers and
loggers
and at the time according to an archived
version of the nature conservancy's
website
they when they were proudly announcing
this deal they said uh these threats
have been
abated because of this acquisition by
the nature conservancy
so it's really interesting now fast
forward two decades to earlier this year
when they put forward this carbon
project and if you look through it
this land is a key part of that carbon
project
and what they're now saying is this land
is now once again
imminently threatened 72 percent of the
trees are going to be cut within five
years
now this is just astounding because this
land is owned by the nature conservancy
they do not clear-cut land that they've
bought
through philanthropic donations
so this scenario that they've put
forward to get carbon revenues is
not really plausible and what that means
is when you have disney coming in
and buying these credits when it
eventually lowers its carbon footprint
because of these credits well that won't
be a credible or truthful claim by
disney
so uh this is this is an organization
that truly understands the
the threat of the issue of of climate
change and
is wanting to do its part to address
this however in this situation it just
appears their
their drive which they've had for
decades to increase the amount of
revenues that it can use for land
preservation work
nature conservancy and many others see
that
carbon credits as a pot of money that
they can tap into
to further their own benevolent aims
but unfortunately what this has resulted
in is
claims of climate progress that just
aren't really happening
so the nature conservancy defends
vigorously these deals
and and they and others will say look
our projects are just following the
rules that these registries set up
um so some would also put some of the
blame on the registries themselves
because they're setting up the rules
which
allow these vaped projects to get up and
sold
so we've reached out to all of the
companies we mentioned in the story
including disney they didn't want to be
interviewed for this story but they all
told us that look we have to rely on the
experts out there and those experts they
say
are these carbon registries that have
been set up
most of these nature conservancy deals
are
set up and sold on this exchange it's
called the american carbon registry
now it's the oldest of these registries
that
allow voluntary carbon credits to be
sold they've been around since
1996. what these offset registries do
is they set up rules and any carbon
offset project
has to follow those rules but there's
this tension that's always there
if the rules are too strict then it's
going to be very hard for carbon offset
projects to get up and running
so there's this this balance going on
where the registries want
rules that attract projects but they
don't want it to be so
strict where it will uh disincentivize
projects from getting listed
one of the the challenges with with
designing carbon offset systems
is that there are normally two people at
the table you have buyers and you have
sellers and to some extent you have
policy makers but
but you know the buyers and the sellers
are really the ones with the expertise
with the with the incentive to really
participate hard
make a lot of things happen uh and the
the challenge there is
is that both of them sort of want the
same thing or they're both happy with
the same thing they're happy with
cost offsets and a lot of them because
that works for their business model
you end up though with nobody really
representing
the atmosphere so to speak nobody's
really representing the climate
in those discussions and so the policies
end up
biasing the whole system and
and you you end up in sort of a race to
the bottom and that's what we've seen
happen
you know when it comes specifically to
the topic of carbon offsets
you i i am a fan of carbon offsets in
the sense that they can help mitigate
climate change
they absolutely can but you know if
we're not going to do it correctly in a
way that actually does help mitigate
climate change
then it's nothing but a distraction and
you know after 30 years
you have to start wondering is it really
just a distraction
and that's really unfortunate but that's
where we are
ultimately what needs to be what needs
to happen is systemic
change you know we're sort of nibbling
around the edges with some of these
different things
we need to change how we produce energy
we need to
change how we transport ourselves we
need to change
what and how we eat you know we we need
systemic change associated with
transitioning to a low-carbon
economy a lot of what we're doing today
is not promoting systemic change it's
sort of trying to stick your
your thumb in the dike uh to preserve
the current system
and and at the end of the day that can't
really
work
[Music]
you